and welcome back everybody so we're
turning our Focus now to the charges in
the Idaho College student murders case
because if convicted Brian coburger
faces some Hefty prison time related to
each of the four victims that were
killed and if the case heads to trial
there's really no telling at least now
what his defense is going to be a common
defense strategy is insanity and that
requires experts to evaluate the
defendant's State of Mind at the time of
the crime but in Idaho a direct Insanity
defense doesn't really exist forensic
psychologist Dr John De la Torre weighs
in on how it's applied and how the
likelihood a likelihood of it fitting
into this case
so in Idaho they're not exactly taking
away mental illness as part of the
defense strategy they're just simply
only going to allow it to be a part of
the overall intentionality that someone
may have when it comes to committing
this crimes so certain crimes right
certain degrees of felonies have certain
kinds of the ways in which someone
intentionally does something so for a
first degree murder the person has to
knowingly or purposefully engage in
these kinds of acts so essentially what
we're saying is that someone of clear
mind decided that they were going to
engage in this act there's very few uh
diagnoses that would lead to someone not
knowing right the the idea that someone
is in their intentionality of knowingly
or purposefully there's very few one of
the most common ones is a psychotic
disorder there's nothing to suggest that
this guy has ever suffered from a
psychotic disorder doesn't mean that he
never did experience these symptoms but
there's nothing that we've seen so far
to indicate that that's active that that
that has occurred and it's certainly
possible that maybe that there were some
things that happened in his past traumas
abuses right obsessive compulsive
disorders autism spectrum disorders the
list can go on and on and on of how many
things that this person could
potentially use but I don't think any of
it's going to be used if he decides not
to speak on his own defense
okay Terry let's make this very clear
for everybody can you break down the
charges against coburger and also any
possible defenses sure I mean he faces
four counts of first degree murder and a
felony burglary charge for his alleged
role in all of these killings now the
murders are considered first degree
because they were allegedly premeditated
and the felony burglary charge that's
based on the fact that kohlberg
allegedly broke into the house to commit
a felony the actual felony was murdered
so Idaho is one of 27 states with the
death penalty so if the prosecution
requests that Cole Burger faces the
possibility of a lethal injection if not
he faces life in prison there are
currently eight people on death row in
Idaho but they've only been two
executions in the past 50 years so I
doubt that he'll get the death penalty
as for his defense Idaho eliminated the
insanity defense in 1982 after John
Hinckley was found not guilty by reason
of insanity for attempting to
assassinate then President Ronald Reagan
but as Dr delatorre said he mentioned
that the defendant can use evidence of
mental illness to claim that he was not
capable of forming the intent to commit
that crime so it'll take some time for
this case to work its way but I
definitely think they're going to make
it a priority yeah I think you're 100
right I'll bring Brian in on this Brian
we often see Insanity defenses in mass
murder cases that not being a real
option here what arguments do you think
that the public defender is going to
make so I think the strongest and
probably the only option here is it
wasn't him I mean today everyone is
applauding the police and their
investigation and the capture of Brian
coburger but don't forget a week ago the
court of public opinion thought they
were botching this investigation I can
imagine a defense attorney jumping on
that and saying hey what we all fought
at the beginning of this investigation
is true and here are all the different
reasons why it's not Brian Coburg or why
it's this person or that person don't
forget even Terry was saying why are the
police letting so many people go so
quickly a defense attorney I think is
going to jump on that rather than trying
to make the argument that hey it was him
but because of some sort of mental break
he doesn't have the men's Raya or the
the mental capacity to commit the crime
that dog I don't think is going to hunt
and we need to see what the evidence is
right we need to understand at least
what's in the probable cause affidavit
because right now a lot of it is based
on speculation once we have a better
understanding then we can start talking
about a legal case